a real relationship is a wrestling match
it's a grappling it's a grappling
phenomena that you both emerge
transformed from and that's what people
want they don't want to push over not
not unless there's something wrong with
them conflict avoided is conflict
delayed and magnified and so
it was a cross-temper mental learning
process for me I had to learn to work
against my temperament in order to
engage in conflict that was necessary
when it was necessary you want someone I
think in a relationship that you can
spar with
and it's partly because
[Music]
you have hard problems to solve and if
the person that you're with isn't
willing to put forward their opinion
then you only have half the cognitive
power that you would otherwise have
you know and hopefully you find someone
who's interestingly different from you
like not so different that you can't
communicate and you have to be careful
of that but interestingly different and
then hopefully they have the ability and
the will to express their opinion and
then your interest stays heightened and
there has to be that tension in a
relationship you know people think well
I want to get along perfectly with my
partner it's like no you you probably
don't you just get bored and then you go
looking for trouble and so you want a
little bit of trouble in the
relationship and a little bit of mystery
and a little bit of combativeness and
and the ability to exchange opinions
forthrightly and one of the rules was
and this has been a rule that Tammy and
I have used in our whole relationship is
like do not agree to something you don't
agree to because the worst thing is is
you negotiate out a settlement and the
person decides they're going to
implement it but really they're
resentful about it because they didn't
want to have any conflict and then their
crab be about it every time they do it
and they do a terrible job and they're
irritated about it and that lasts
forever if you can't run away then you
can solve your problems because it might
be okay well I'm stuck with you
so how about we fix things
because the alternative is we're going
to be in a boxing match for the next 40
years that's the alternative so and you
think you're going to fix problems
without something like that hanging over
your head there isn't a chance you'll
just avoid them because that's what
people do I do believe that that spark
that's outside of voluntary control is a
necessary precondition for a
long-lasting relationship I do believe
though that if it's there you still have
to work very hard to maintain it you
know what do you want from a partner
fundamentally what what do you want need
you're blessed with the fact that you
find each other attractive and I think
it's very difficult for the relationship
too begin or proceed or sustain itself
without that well you want someone that
you can trust you want someone that you
can build a view of the future with and
you want someone that you can negotiate
with and that's very hard to negotiate
with people because they have to tell
you what they think they have to know
what they want or figure it out they
have to tell you what they want they
have to be satisfied and when they get
what they want which is also a very
difficult thing to manage and you have
to continually update that because your
life goes through different stages and
people also don't understand because
they tend to think that that all
romantic interactions should be
spontaneous it's like well if that's
your theory then you might as well just
give up right now if you're going to get
married because that like the only
reason you can think that is because you
don't have enough responsibility to make
romantic entanglement virtually
impossible and what happens when you're
married especially when you have little
kids is that and and you both have a job
let's say is you're so busy that the
probability that you're going to find
time for spontaneous Mutual interaction
is decreases to zero and so if that's
what you're hoping for then you're never
going to have it and so what you have to
do is you have to make time for each
other and when you're establishing a
relationship well you put some effort
into it you know you you decide that
you're going to go out for dinner and
you dress up to some degree and you know
you try to present yourself to each
other in some half ways acceptable
manner but then people somehow think
that once they're married that the same
amount of effort isn't necessary and
that's wrong I would say war effort is
necessary on the same front and you have
to think it through it's like you know
if you don't want to be bitter about the
intimate element of your relationship
how much time do you have to spend
together each week and my my rule of
thumb sort of derived from Clinical
observations is that you need to spend
90 minutes a week with your partner
talking
and that means you're telling each other
about your life and staying in touch you
know so that you each know what the
other is up to and you're discussing
what needs to be done to keep the
household running smoothly and you're
laying out some mutually acceptable
vision of how the next week or the next
months are going to go together right so
that that keeps your narratives locked
together like a like the strands in a
rope you need that for 90 minutes or you
drift apart and you need to spend
intimate time together at least once a
week and probably more like twice and
that has to be negotiated and if you
don't negotiate it and if you don't make
it a priority then it won't happen in
all likelihood and then well well then
you don't have it and that's a
catastrophe because there's not that
many things in life that are you know
intrinsically what would you say
engaging and meaningful and pleasurable
and also bonding all of that and if you
let that go then well part of you dies
and part of the relationship dies and if
I offered everything I could to a
partner who would I be
you work on that ask that question just
ask just ask yourself okay okay what do
they want clean that's not a bad start
reasonably good physical shape so
healthy productive
generous honest the harder you work on
offering other people what they need and
want
the more people will line up to play
with you so it's the wrong question it's
like how can I be the best partner
possible
and then you think well if I do that
people will just take advantage of me
and that's the non-naive objection right
because the naive persons think well
I'll be good and everyone will treat me
right it's like the cynic says they'll
all be good and someone will
take me out
and then you think well what do you do
about that objection and the answer is
well
you factor that in
that's why you're supposed to be what is
it
soft as a dove and as wise as a serpent
it's like I know you're full of snakes
I know it
maybe I know it more than you do
but we'll play anyways what's so cool
about that is that even though the
person you're dealing with is full of
snakes
if you offer your hand in trust and it's
real you will evoke the best in them